42 on a thursday morning nevada
continues to have one of the highest
unemployment rates in the entire country
john
alex our kate houston explores how the
pandemic is impacting the job market
it is extremely frustrating ryan kessler
has been out of work since may of last
year
when he was laid off from his position
as director of beverage at the strat
i need to find something to
be able to provide for my family kessler
is on job sites all day
every day but has not yet heard back and
he's not alone
people that have experienced numerous
years of experience that
are just sitting here waiting for
something to happen this week kessler
applied to boston's fish house and bar
a new restaurant opening in tivoli
village although they're looking to fill
dozens of positions very few have showed
up to their hiring fairs
very shocked that nobody's really come
to
come out to apply for a job and
we have a manager position we have
servers
cooks we probably are looking to hire 75
to 100 people here
vice president brian sword says he had
to bring in workers from his restaurant
in chicago to help out
our plan is to open up next week i'm
ready to go i just need employees now
on the strip resorts world has received
an influx of applications
kessler is one of 75 thousand that are
looking to fill
6 000 open positions the people who are
out of work there's so much
talent to pull from that it's hard to
for anybody to get a job or a new job
although it's been a difficult process
kessler says he's staying positive
and enjoying the quality time with his
family this experience
has definitely taught me not to give up
continue pressing on and continuing to
better myself and better the people
around me kate houston
8 news now we certainly know it is
challenging for
a lot of you out there right now and if
you are looking for work we do have a
resource that is online to help you
find folks that are hiring right now
just go to eight newsnow dot com
click on the community tab then go to
the job board we can try and put you in
with the position that you're looking
for
alex